I think guns is a good analog to this I
think we need more constitutional carry
across the board I think people that use
guns to kill the innocent are evil and
must be stopped so my view is like
individuals have their rights but just
because you have access to something
doesn't mean it's your fault that
another person did something bad so if
there are groomers true and and abusers
trying to come into the space I'm not
going to blame two guys on a farm
minding their own business well thank
you so it's not your fault what I would
say is I I actually I agree it's kind of
ironic because Tim says he doesn't
believe that the slippery slope started
with gay marriage and you were arguing
that it probably did I would actually
push it back before that and so what I
believe and I believe we've talked about
this when you were on the show uh before
but I'm Catholic I believe marriage is
between a man and a woman
I also believe that uh sex is supposed
to be unitive and pro-creative and when
we as a society decided that we were
going to accept the normalization of
artificial contraceptive methods we
basically
pushed this giant boulder down the hill
that was going to entirely interrupt and
subvert our understanding of human
sexuality and what it is so a lot of
people will say well this is the moment
where we started rolling down the
slippery slope or this is where we
should have stopped but my point is as
soon as that happened we had pushed the
Boulder and it wasn't going to stop
until we tried to turn it around and
reverse everything
I I don't I I just think
as I stated if there's a some basic
question of two people who want to mind
their own business I'm fine with it if
someone then tries to use that to then
do something evil we just say no you
know we recognize the difference but
they I will but then I guess you and I
we we just fundamentally disagree over
what's evil well and I certainly think
too the the when it came to the question
of gay marriage uh this is back what was
it proposition eight in California was
that was a big thing they voted against
it judges there was that famous line
from Jack Black where he was like
pretending to be Jesus on stage he says
your nation was built on separation of
church and state and I was confused
because I was like isn't that an
argument against gay marriage like if
marriage is a religious institution then
wouldn't you be in fact arguing for
civil unions and not marriage by saying
that I never understood but my position
was always was always was equal rights
or whatever but I do certainly
understand this does lead this this I I
do believe gay marriage led to the
question of polyamory and polygamy and
and things like that because then you
start asking more questions about out
what what defines the limitations of
whether or not someone has the right to
tax benefits and access and why would it
be limited to only one other person the
one I'm seeing a lot right now is uh
just good friend get married and they're
like but I really like they're my life
partner like they like them more than
anyone else and they've been in my life
longer so why would I get married to
someone I'm dating versus just like my
best friend forever well uh and that is
another question about unions right this
would be what marriage was in a
post-merit society
well I'm seeing this more and more all
the time like the the entire reason that
we decided as a society collectively to
keep track at least at the government
level of who is getting married is
because we wanted to know who was
accountable for which children and also
who were making children that was the
point of it uh as as something that was
enshrined legislatively and so once you
move outside of that and this is why
I've mentioned I think this starts with
contraceptives because then you no
longer believe that marriage is about
having children about having a family
and so then it can basically become
about anything after that point you just
totally broaden the definition and I
think it's impossible after that to come
to a point and say like well this is
where we're gonna stop it you've already
opened that Pandora's Box like you no
longer have that reason-based definition
of what it's for
and you you either have to turn around
and do away with all of it or you're
just going to get more of it and this is
something that like straight people will
get mad at me for too because they'll
say well you're criticizing
contraceptives and I think one argument
that was made by a lot of gay rights
activists during uh the the 90s through
2010s when this was uh much more hot
button issue was well conservatives
actually are not living and walking the
walk when it comes to this stuff because
they are using contraceptives and they
are getting divorced and that's actually
true that was one of the things that I
believed to open the door for all of
this boy Paul VI would be so happy right
now yeah I mean yeah Saint Paul really
he's really very excited nice nice job
done yeah thank you he did yeah he said
basically years ago yeah it's very
prophetic yeah I wonder the main issue
for me was always about uh equal rights
and access not the definition of a
family I actually thought that if if
marriage is done in churches and in
temples and synagogues and its view food
widely as a religious function in this
country then yeah then there's a
separation of church and state and for
the government to mandate a church
provide a ceremony or whatever would
seemingly be a violation of that yeah
this is christianization I was going to
say this is this is what we talk about
with the post-christian nation obviously
the the state realized the vital
importance of marriage that they adopted
it and it became a state thing the
question is should it still be a state
thing and I would argue it should
there's a value to the family there's a
value to to to moms and dads and keeping
track of children and it used to be for
the purity of the bloodline also that we
weren't making sure that you were
marrying your first cousin or
etc etc that was a very important role
of it but the the state has adopted
principles of religion because it was
valuable for society it's very much even
from the secular point of view someone
like Thomas Jefferson one of our great
Virginians as a proud Virginian now I'll
say you know wasn't himself particularly
Christian same with Ben Franklin but
realized the benefit in society yeah so
what happens when we become
post-christian is we throw away all of
that and we think Society is going to
continue as it is and it's not it's the
same as if we get rid of uh you know the
same as we're trying to adopt a
smartphone you know kids have been the
same for for five thousand ten thousand
a hundred and fifty thousand years and
now kids are totally different because
of this little device and we can't adopt
fast enough yeah I mean it hacks your it
kind of hacks your brain but I just want
to mention because you brought up Paul
the six but and I and you're right but I
just want to mention this usually when
I'll make these arguments I'll get hit
with you're arguing from a Catholic
perspective or making a religious
argument true that I'm Catholic but
you'll notice I did not invoke uh divine
revelation at all
but but no no there's nothing wrong with
it without no no I just want to mention
this when I give that explanation I'm
speaking like from the perspective of
what makes sense for a functioning
Society I'm not I I at no point said
well the reason we have to do it this
way is because you know when two
baptized Christians get married and have
a sacramental marriage and they're
trying to get each other to have it I
believe all that's true but my argument
from this is from a perspective of why
is the government looking at this in the
first place yeah and there are plenty of
non-religious reasons for that and we
are not a healthy society and I love
that you said that I'm looking at this
for what is a healthy society and what I
find one of the more fascinating things
to do is go back and look at surveys
that have been done for 20 40 50 100
Years of of Happiness of depression
levels and every single survey shows
that we are a less happy we are more
depressed we are a we are not a healthy
Society right now do you agree with it
do you agree with Sheamus's
interpretation of the purpose of family
absolutely how do you how do you
reconcile that you know that that's for
God is going to ask me that question
question one day because it doesn't make
any sense I'm a total contradiction but
I agree with them 100 I grew up Catholic
you know I realize what I am living
right now is not in accordance with with
my faith but I also understand that you
know I've for God how many years 20 30
years I tried to pretend I wasn't and
I'm like well that's that's it you know
what actually made me uh a couple things
made me come out and I was in my late
20s when it happened was
um
uh one thing that made me come out was
how much I I uh didn't like gay people
because of their their vulgarity their
promiscuity Pride parades and I thought
I don't want to be anything like that so
I can be better so why you know like why
why are we allowing gay people to have
this awful reputation because they
brought it upon themselves quite frankly
that was one of the things that made me
come out nothing that made me come out
were a lot of the church scandals
um you know I grew up very devoutly
Catholic and I would see the number of
of things happen and everyone would sort
of absolve themselves and say well you
know that's unfortunate but we've moved
on and I thought well wait a second like
that Bishop is still going to be the
bishop and he knows all these things
happen in his diocese but I can't marry
Andrew because that's wrong I'm like oh
wait a second holding by the church like
how come that Bishop can keep his
diocese when all this is happening and
but I can't marry this so and that's a
knock on the church I admit it and God
will judge me for it I hope he's lenient
I pray to him every day that he will be
but uh there are a couple things that
made me come out but but that doesn't
mean when it comes to society and the
role of the family I will change my
beliefs that's an interesting point
about the scandals in the church and the
inaction they've taken because perhaps
the corruption starts in the church and
their in their inaction on these
scandals yeah so there's definitely some
truth in that I would say um that you
know God is going to judge all of us at
the end of our lives but um of the
things you've discussed I don't think
the thing he's going to judge you for is
pointing out that there are bad people
in the church who did unbelievably
horrible things and I've spoken on this
in the past I think that anyone who is
involved with the abusive children or
covering up the abuse of children not
only has to be removed from their
position in the church but they need to
be prosecuted to the fullest possible
extent of the law I think it's an
absolute travesty what occurred it's
unbelievably horrific but that said
and that is an example of there being
really horrible people in the church
doing really horrible things but that
doesn't justify rejecting Church
teachings in other ways I love how the
many leftists will often bring up the
abuse at churches as some kind of gotcha
to people who are concerned about what's
happening in schools but it's like let
me ask you do you think that the parents
in these in these districts and these
diocese or whatever do you think that
they're like totally fine with what's
going on when they find out about it do
you think that they're just like no one
tell anybody what just happened or do
you think there's like Fury rage and
demands well I'll put it this way there
are many diocese that have rules that
say like no you know if you're a cleric
or you work from the church you cannot
be alone with a child and I have not
known a single priest who said this is
unfair you can't do this of course we
should be allowed to be alone with
Children And yet when Ron DeSantis in
Florida signs legislation which says you
can't have secret conversations with
children about sex that you then tell
them to withhold from their parents the
entire community in this country erupts
with crisis
yeah it's don't say hey right thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time